ANTHONY DOUGLAS: I'm
Anthony Douglas, founder
and CEO of Hole19.
Hole19 is building the
largest and most engaged
network of golfers.
We're connecting
the world of golf.
We want to be part of
the golfer's journey,
before, during, and
after the round of golf.
Golf has always been
a passion of mine.
The idea came about
in 2007 when I
was working with a golf coach.
So it was a platform
to track my stats
and connect with a golf
coach to help me improve.
Starting a company in
that space is a great way
to blend my passion
with business.
We built the
product in Portugal.
We were in Lisbon.
We found a design team that
could help us build it.
Four and a half,
five years later,
we're close to a million users.
The moment we found
out about Android Wear,
it was clear to us that we
had to be there from day one.
In the golf industry already,
technology-- actually pulling
out your phone-- is
often frowned upon.
And we just felt that a
smart watch on your wrist
just made sense.
Combining hardware
and software, we
felt that Android Wear was
the perfect solution for us.
FABIO CARBALLO: Since
the launch of Wear,
we have seen a lot of positive
feedback from the users.
And we have grown our
user base more than double
on the last six months.
We've seen that our
Android Wear users have
a 40% monthly active usage.
Android Wear brings a much more
engaged community to our app.
In fact, some of our users
are only using Hole19
on the Android Wear.
And we think that it is a
consequence of the big effort
that we put into developing it.
Moving to Android
Wear as a developer
was relatively easy,
given the quality
of the wearable libraries.
One of the most important things
on the on-course experience
was checking the
distances to the green.
That was a core feature that
we had to move from the phone
to the watch.
One thing that you
have to take into
account when developing
apps for Wear,
is that the phone and the
app communicate at all times.
For this, we have used
the data layer API that
makes our life really easy.
Because it is just a matter
of exchanging the right
small portions of data.
With the new launch
of Android Wear 2.0,
we have access to
a whole new set
of features that can
improve the user experience.
We are already using
the Complications API,
because we want the user to
feel connected with online team.
We want him to look
to the watch face
and have quick
access to information
like his handicap,
his average score,
how many days has passed
from the last time he
had played golf.
ANTHONY DOUGLAS:
It's been amazing
looking back when this
company was started,
when I was in my basement
mapping golf courses
for six hours.
Little did I know that
a few years later we'd
have 1 million users.
I didn't really expect
it to be this powerful.
I also didn't expect to bring
30 people into this company.
It's been really rewarding.